[Music]
[Applause]
chris angel reveals his seven-year-old
son johnny's cancer is in remission more
than six years after his diagnosis
today is johnny christopher day and we
want to thank all of you for the amazing
love and prayers and support
over the years
johnny was diagnosed with acute
lymphoblastic leukemia in october 2015
when he was just 20 months old
my reaction in that moment was
disbelief
i thought it happened to
the other person
not to you
he initially went into remission in june
2016 and eti was with chris shortly
before the cancer returned in 2019. we
get blood tests every
month or two and everything is coming
back with all signs saying that he's
remaining in remission and we pray that
he remains there for the rest of his
life fast forward to 2022 and good news
johnny is back in remission
chris who shares johnny with chenille
benson celebrated his son's improved
health by sharing a 13-minute short film
titled 10.95 which represents the total
number of days he was in treatment
we've spent most of johnny's life in and
out of clinics and hospitals and
it's so weird it feels like it's just
normal now you know what i mean like
we're here
so much that it's it's kind of part of
our home
the 54 year old magician released a
short film on instagram monday and in a
press release chris explains quote this
is our family story but it's really the
story of every family unfortunate enough
to have a child with cancer this
horrible disease impacts not just the
children but all those that love them
our hope is that as many people as
possible can see 1095 and be moved to
help so we can continue to raise
awareness improve treatment and one day
find a cure
one child every two minutes is diagnosed
with cancer
cancer doesn't discriminate i want to
try to be a voice for these kids i want
to try to help
these families that are going through
the toughest time of their life
and
let them know that they're not alone
you know what i mean
there's magic in the world and that
magic is love
chris adds on instagram that the short
film which shows footage from the
doctor's visits and emotional private
moments is quote the most important post
he's ever shared if i could take this
disease from him i would in a heartbeat
and before asking his followers to watch
and share the project to raise awareness
and help find a cure chris writes quote
today our son johnny christopher will
finally ring the bell symbolizing his
remission and the end of his treatment
i feel like all of this success that
i've been so blessed to have is really
for a greater cause and that is
pediatric cancer one child every two
minutes is diagnosed with it so if you'd
like to help out you can go to
chrisangel.com click the help button and
donate and know that 100 of every cent
you donate will go to research and
treatment for these children suffering
with this horrible disease
[Music]
you